E aí
[Música]
e eu conheço alimentação fazer uma
pergunta uma reflexão para vocês Será
que hoje a gente utiliza a terra e não
sei por centrais da melhor maneira
possível por quê que eu faço uma
pergunta na hora que eu tirar o nosso
futuro a gente tem que ter certezas Mas
ele tem obviamente muitos dados que
corroboram a gente consegue fazer
diversas previsões nos previsões que a
gente tem principalmente são dados da
fao da ONU é que a população nos
próximos 30 anos até 150 eu achei a
próximo de 10 vezes de pessoas essa
população não vai crescer tem um tem
país Esse envolvimento e países já
desenvolvidos a gente está falando de
países e continentes com a África que
tem crescimento em cada vez maiores que
são as regiões que vão ter um um
acréscimo população muito grande que tem
taxa de crescimento vegetativo bem altas
Então não é contrária a isso é melhor
que a gente olha a idade da média de
idade proporcional desse locais está
vendo que na verdade também está tendo
uma mudança nesse sentido Tem cada vez
mais adultos as pessoas estão
conseguindo ver mais tempo a média de
idade das pessoas só ficam mais altas
e também eu levo muito o consumo
calórico essas pessoas ou seja não
encontrar todos esses fatores a gente
existe o entendimento de que vamos ter
que aumentar o a produção de alimentos
na faixa de 70 porcento nos próximos 30
anos com isso a hora que a gente pensa
nesse dado para colocar de outra forma é
como se tivesse falando aqui nos
próximos 30 anos a gente vai ter que
produzir mais alimentos do que a gente
produziu nos oito mil anos anteriores
essa data por pensão a quantidade
absurda de alimentos é o preço que eu
começo por essa pergunta é como uma
reflexão e agora começa a trazer um
pouco mais dado você entender porque tem
uma pergunta extremamente vai né mas não
é só isso do outro lado na hora que eu
tiver precisa de uma questão e como a
gente utiliza o nosso espaço nossa terra
pensando em que o nosso Globo a maior
parte dele é água são mais oceanos a
gente tem uma limitadas para gente Para
poder todos alimentos seja agropecuária
seja
a agricultura pecuária e outras formas
que a gente possa ter então com base
nisso a gente pega toda a gente vai
descontando essas áreas que são oceanos
Mares áreas de um deserto coisas que
tinham consegue utilizar a gente olhar
disponível tanto para produção comprar
moradia que faz sentido ele tá falando
que hoje a gente é utilize cerca de
cinquenta por cento dessa área e pasmo
está falando graça desse cinquenta por
cento mais ou menos 77 por cento é agro
pecuária extensiva então com base nesses
dados a gente tem que ter entendimento
do que simplesmente aumentar a área
produtiva uma coisa que promete não faz
sentido primeiro que está-te matando uma
flora e fauna ali tirando a imagem
origem daquele lugar e para mim não é
esse uso adequado para terra eu gostaria
que a gente faça o máximo possível
disponível olhar as nativas ainda
pensando nisso a gente tem que entender
se existem outras formas o outro todos
na cadeia também e claro como toda a
cadeia ela tem seus problemas suas
complexidades
e principalmente na parte de pessoas se
a gente olhar estavam da da ONU hoje a
gente perde cerca de um terço de toda a
produção que a gente tem de alimentos
esse um texto representa mais ou menos
algo em torno de 1,3 bilhão de toneladas
ano de alimentos perdidas no mercado que
eu trabalho muito muito mais diretamente
essas penas eficiente de hortaliças
frutas verduras as acontecem tanto
dentro da cadeia produtiva é tanto
depois na net Pimenta então eu tô
falando dentro da cadeia na mente da
Porteira né que a gente fala Fazenda São
prova de pragas e intempéries pessoa tem
uma exposição falta de verdade quem
consegue sair do processo de uma série
de problemas e depois que saem e
principalmente em países como o Brasil
que é a cadeia ela é um pouco um chá de
rústico ainda você temos diversos
problemas de acondicionamento de produto
falta de embalagem falta de cada de frio
dentre outros vários problemas que esse
produto ele chega no consumo era mentira
um pouco deteriorado com algumas
complexidades ali de
O que é uma qualidade mais baixa e os
pontos que para gente e aí eu pergunto
para vocês vocês fazer essa reflexão com
vocês fazem as coisas desses produtos
restante frutas e verduras hortaliças no
geral o nosso entendimento é que a gente
faz esse tipo de escolha para um
processo extremamente visual repente
próprio Furiosas e frutas e legumes
realmente frutas legumes a gente também
quando não é ou não é algo embalada a
gente consegue também teu tatu Mas no
geral é uma atenção visual Então são
produtos que eles já chegam uma
deficiência como um problema com
machucado com uma marca de inseto no
geral gente acaba descartam esse produto
e também no ponto de venda se tem uma
perda gigantesca desses alimentos
e a para isso a gente tem diversas
diversas formas de como solucionar para
mim eu aqui todo esse processo seja
aumentar eficiência produtividade no
campo seja reduzir problemas na cadeia
de suprimento seja a gente trazer novas
formas de cultivo a tecnologia está
sempre por trás disso e a tecla gente
vai solucionar esses problemas que vai
trazer novas possibilidades para gente
conseguir é trazer esse problema para um
jejum muito mais comercial e a gente
conseguiu solucionar de maneira
Econômica antes de água também porque o
custo esse produto está extremamente
importante não adianta a gente faz uma
solução totalmente diferente e não casa
no mercado que ela tá é um produto que
no geral tem baixo alongado então gente
tem que pensar muito bem como fazer isso
algumas dessas pernas tecnologias e
técnicas de produção como por exemplo a
fazendas verticais elas trazem diversas
vantagens como por exemplo a produção
durante local portão ficou instalação de
fazendas verticais urbanas
e para mim esperar que se faça uma
produção totalmente Urbana no ambiente
que com produtividade que pode chegar
até 100 vezes mais para dar o do campo
ou seja tá tirando mais necessidade de
área gigantesca aumente isso não tem
muita coisa se descobrirem quantidade de
que tipo de produto se validar as datas
produzir hoje eu já tem Produções
mundiais é de folhosas como alface
rúcula espinafre os produtos algumas
frutas contam automático morango gotas
tipos de produtos como apenas um
cogumelos dá para se produzir um sistema
Pensando principalmente que a pecuária
hoje em dia é uma fonte de proteína
animal e mesmo na verdade os os Fundos
não serem na verdade mesmo fio aí na
verdade é um sistema não tiver um ótimo
substituto para esse né as pessoas em
cada vez mais pensado nisso virados
menos do que estaria no comer um
pouquinho de carne segunda sem carne é
essa pessoas viram mesmo é vegetarianos
E veganos então é uma ótima fonte de
proteína também e altamente
o sistema ele tem diversas vantagens em
questão de sustentabilidade em produção
é um como economia de recursos como a
água mais ou menos assim por cento
camisa de fertilizantes elimina
agrotóxicos o seu ambiente que já tá
dentro do local de consumo então se ele
não tivesse processos de movimentações a
ser nesse sistema os tem uma série de
vantagens e que eu falei tem um leque
nesse descobrir e desenvolver continuar
melhorando e alguém se vê se consegue se
fazer também para os tipos até mesmo
proteína animal não entrando em questões
de direitos animais em certa mas se tem
projetos de algumas fazendas já e como
se fosse um apartamento para galinhas
por exemplo fazer a baixo Então na
verdade o termo seus nervos ficaria
muito mais entanto hoje é muito mais
utilizado para produção de de furiosos
legumes de frutas mas não só isso em
todo o outro lado de técnicas de eu acho
que hoje não estão vendo e procure
entendendo que existe é tanto
substitutos de carne né então de pega
empresa sei que estão na verdade
um hambúrguer linguiça nuggets outras
formas de trazer um sistema de carne e
seus substitutos que não seja origem
animal que é mais insustentável que tem
um sabor textura e outras
características sejam semelhantes e dos
lados várias tem um processo porque isso
aqui é o futuro desse tipo de alimento
empresas precisam de Israel e algumas
outras alguns lugares no mundo que estão
olhando muito isso que na verdade eu que
inicialmente são carnes cultivadas em
laboratório a partir de células animais
pra substituir esse tipo de alimento é
de uma maneira que não tenha nenhuma
parte da qualidade de Crueldade Animal
com os animais mesmo antes eu já baixa
de centro e na região tipo tive só o que
a gente vai conseguir então a gente não
tem todo um descarte relacionado Aquilo
é muito mais eficientes economiza muita
água você não tá pensando fazer que é um
animal para bater né mas tá querendo a
carne você já vai consumir então tem uma
série de processos que estão se
desenvolvendo no mercado de Tecnologia
Olá pessoal mais possível desse tipo de
sistema é mas também não é só isso é
verdade tem outras técnicas que são até
de outras culturas que é contra os
ocidentais estão cada vez mais pegando
entendendo que dá dá para se usar de
maneiras que não tem um tabu cultural
tão grande por exemplo a Então vou
fingir que é o consumo de insetos ela se
for pensar os grilos e são ótimas fontes
de proteína mais de 65 por cento do Peso
deles é proteína EA grandes políticos e
conseguia até resíduos biológicos outras
coisas que hoje são muitos problemas de
outras cadeias que a gente conseguiria
fazer um círculo mais fechado com base
nisso tem muita gente que se mexeu nos
Estados Unidos e na Europa de tão
começando a introduzir alguns alimentos
com farinha de grilo presente com uma
base por dentro
a hora que a gente pensa nisso só formas
resolver esse problema só formas de
reduzir o consumo e os emissões de gás
carbônico então uma produção de de grilo
outros dez vezes menos área para atingir
a mesma quantidade proteína do que uma
produção é a pecuária bovina no ar
quente olha ela ela já era mais ou menos
100 vezes menos gás carbônico e o efeito
estufa do que o mesmo processo mesmo a
quantidade de proteína gerada Então na
verdade às vezes na verdade a gente
precisa até pensar um pouco mais como
que a gente tá utilizando nosso próprio
alimento se a gente está fazendo todas
as coisas corretas a gente não pode
abrir um pouco mais nosso leque de
consumo entender se tem coisas que gera
um pouco mais de valor e são mais
sustentáveis no longo prazo com base
nisso eu faço uma pergunta uma reflexão
final com vocês que é será que nós
dentro das nossas casas primeiro a gente
já tá pensando de uma maneira que a
gente conseguir o máximo desperdício
então isso eu acho que talvez é o
o mais rápido de se desenvolver e gerar
um pouco menos hoje esse é um pouco mais
sustentável longo prazo o primeiro a
gente tá usando o máximo todos alimentos
que a gente compra se não tiver a gente
não tá desperdiçando nada em casa
segunda Será que a gente compra esse
alimentos da melhor maneira possível
Será que a gente não compra alimentos de
uma maneira sem pensar será que está
comprando os melhores fornecedores que
tem práticas sustentáveis eu acho que
essa reflexão com todo mundo deve fazer
e da retenção se no ponto Será que hoje
que a gente se alimenta Será que a gente
não consegue pensar normal uma dieta um
pouco diferente se a gente para comer
carne todo dia isso não reflexão
totalmente pessoal mas que eu fiz que
todos nós podemos fazer entender que
todos devemos fazer algo diferente do
ambiente para a gente entender com que a
gente usa a os recursos naturais que a
gente tem hoje em sendo que a gente vai
passar de cada vez mais eles são você
cada vez mais preciosos e importantes na
nossa vida então eu isso Eva é gostaria
de agradecer a Espero que tem um
aprendido alguma coisa eu e feito um
pouco mais assim refl
bom obrigado